to deny that there's a difference to say
gender is over is radical stuff that
should not be taught to third graders
third graders that's dangerous and if
you extrapolate and continue on then it
leads to no gen to gender neutral
bathrooms which they're doing at the
school district next to us they're doing
that throughout the country and gender
neutral bathrooms and locker rooms and
that's just not safe that is a dangerous
situation to keep them combined in the
same space yeah
how do you feel about the gender-neutral
bathrooms and locker rooms well i agree
with my fellow my fellow mat over here
loudoun county is a famous case of the
daily wire we helped uncover uh there
was a gender non-conforming boy in a
dress who went into it to a girl's
restroom and raped violently raped uh a
young girl after that happened that's
when this the school district decided oh
you know what now we're going to open up
the restrooms and uh invite the the boys
in with the girls now here's what
happens because we hear a lot about well
gender non-conforming people transgender
people uh it makes them feel bad if they
don't if they're not given access to the
bathrooms they want
well okay so they have their feelings
what about the feelings of the girls who
are getting raped there are many girls
and many women who are speaking out and
saying we want privacy in our facilities
we don't want a man in the in the
bathroom with us and then what we hear
from people
what we hear from this side i did not
say that we want open bathrooms where
anyone can go in what we hear from this
side is that well their feelings don't
matter we're not going who cares
you just have to deal with it right
because the transgender people the
gender non-conforming people it's it's
their feelings that take priority i'm
not trying to minimize your concern
around it but i don't know that it's a
safety issue
um and uh you usually still have another
bathroom that you can go to
my daughter would not feel safe or
secure if she had to share a bathroom or
a gender-neutral locker room with boys